start
this there's tampering
here refer to
secondary this vehicle came from Prim
and right now we going to do an
inspection on the vehicle the passenger
is coming from Rosa where he lives is
going to work the subject right now is
claiming that he's in a hurry that's
usually a red flag on us saying trying
to pressure our inspection so we going
to see what is in the
vehicle we usually start from the front
and work yourself
[Music]
around there's nothing
here we tap for see if there's any uh if
there's a solid feeling or something
like that it might be indicator there
something might be in there we'll check
the back
seats see if there's anything here
here we see for any any tampering
anything like that tampering means they
remove something and usually those are
indicators there Mak something in the
vehicle you can see there's tampering
here there's bolts here there's are
Factory but they have been removed and
that's an indicator there's might be
something in the vehicle we we're going
to continue checking on the vehicle
there's any additional tampering on the
car that's already a red flag on the
vehicle there might be something in
there the bolts have been scuffed like
they've been hit with a ratchet or
something like that that's a usually red
flag the the seat has been removed
that's not normal on a vehicle to have a
seat
removed now we're going to call our K9
Officer
[Music]
that's a good
alert good boy good boy there a positive
alert SEC the
subject
[Music]